yeah definitely has been doing these
bits you know we got some update updates
with the looser side of the bracket guys
go ahead and uh talk about it
ooh the jaw and a heavy favorite in this
LCQ i I mean a lot of people were had
their eyes on him eliminated by mogul
Korea stepping in they go put putting
into that and then hero on the other
side one I guess that means that a teeth
and now hero are the last remaining
players off it all no cost him I'm not
sure what's happened to cost him as well
as he out because I know he was in the
loser but he wasn't Lucius archery and
hero did eliminate fighting spiritual
fight expert out of the tournament as
well
damn okay but here we go thailand vs
pakistan book versus a tea but this is a
big match this is imagine i feel like
whoever wins this can end up winning the
whole thing oh yeah oh yeah and it's
gonna be the jin kazama for book hmm I
like it
and we're taking its a Howard estate
yeah I mean the damage level when we
have seen this match anymore it's been
mostly in a few miss favor because that
forward for you can jump over it and
that kind of mood gets neutralized this
matchup in a way you gotta be careful
you really need to pick your shots yeah
I don't feel like book is the fort
fortune though you know I think that's
what he really has a bunch of and since
the wall broken there we go
go against the grain rate starting it
off here let's see oh what a parry he
had ready for some of the big sabzi I
was looking for for book how he deals
with this board court for neutral how he
deals with some of these very very
threatening options that Akuma had
those react to go from Harry's and chaps
and it was go get it behind book here
and I'm gonna talk about his hope and it
be covered and then I believe was
probably one of the first spots where
really saw the pack Sunday become coming
to the the tournament scene it really
start wrecking everybody then again it
don't you take it master yes yes peoples
have been studying character obviously
so they're both down for the ten
twenties when we block in a logbook wall
carried on a good set of it sort he has
a bar Mia's record the way down could
still be really dangerous
let's go pull up the park backs and the
golden he's totally prepared in the
crowd is he relaxed on the field is that
that's creepy block of authority will
that that we got to talk about it's a
Peterbilt being much slower that is a
bigger mistake than exactly a great
point to be careful I mean he cannot
make those kind of mistakes especially
if you need that damage output you have
to work even harder now to get these
round folks gotta stay sharp here
I live with a big life he's using that
for for now he's kind of trying to maybe
foursome to jump yes keep trying to back
up perfect I don't doesn't get it go
very far heading the route get the round
round three Dungey put good stuff as a
bar me it's work with going into the
next round
can't he utilize it glad you mentioned
that earlier to write the fort for right
now is controlling so much that I mean
it's horse you could see if you have to
go through the air and try to get a
little another approach yeah look at
that
using the calm with this I'm able to
catch it and get some decent damage here
and positioning that's there for think
yeah closer to the wall but book right
now fighting back on the other side
yeah chap throw off the deeper flavor
that's definitely shows I just thought
his hope work here man you know this is
good Oh down for finally gets to connect
this time there's a fork or not a
counter at this time though the quartz
closed
oh he's fishing for that down - he wants
it yeah it was right time to do it like
a matter that could be the down to guess
right old players here get support for
again damage is it
[Applause]
look at game number one I almost spit my
pity you could really tell Brooke has
done his homework the defense Okuma
defendant Lucas Alford he didn't run
into a single doubt - it was entrapment
it's the confidence in the school said
that he's using yeah he is he is
actually putting in work here he's
forcing a reaction out of a teef that we
haven't really seen him he was able to
control matchups in previous permits
that we've seen at least on stream but
right now that was full control for
yellow floral control blocking the
downforce floating the diamond flip you
know keeping them out with that with
forward for constant adaptations that
book is playing really well can often
bring it back though
confidence and patience - is the big
thing
exactly confidence in just having that
split second where you don't hesitate
where you know exactly what you're doing
in the matchup that goes a long way
right now it's a big jump in and this
could change things even more over the
fort for starting to change it up down
maybe a team taking more liberties here
offensively yeah it definitely started
off a lot more festive but it still
gonna help it catch up in this round
yeah he neutralizes the mix-up as well
so you don't get you know you get
damaged you don't get any mix ups very
very good option here we go he's gonna
push board the ball
[Applause]
he dropped the combo opportunity there
he had it and just unfortunate there
guys they funk is another jab out the
air the reactions are on point right now
man he's got a pimple that's a train
reaction man like he's so consistent
when business attire says before yeah
all right working building that first
meter gonna have to be careful he's been
using a lot of that for fourth floor
book hasn't really been using the ferry
again to deal with it rude but do you
know he hasn't you know he got those
well I think he's using get a lot
because you have been ducking those
downpours you know at all is just that
nice have you off it with a good on to
back to around strike finishes okay that
was the first down to that he was able
to land the set so far and he's already
trying to rewrite that first would it be
like you know I gave you that one let me
get back if you just mentality it's like
it's adjusting to books time right these
took a little second to learn it yeah
and I seem to have a better handle on it
that's where it's really scared once a
good was in full control there's like
almost no way out
you're working again almost half that
meter let's see what he does
oh well here we go modest a little bit
late you shall try yeah using the demon
pom actually beats the jab option to
float so it's a very good uptown option
yeah that's the proper - it's like yes
do it early cast in the mid yet to know
that there's gonna be a reaction yeah if
book let him land you might have been
able to get a hit yeah but now cooking
like sidestepping hop kick or something
right yeah oh actually no because he's
got he's got a really good recovery man
that demon pump yeah but definitely has
to do something you're gonna fix up in
this favor
yes that might be it here we go ha this
is gonna hurt against the wall - yeah do
it here's hoping for a jump away or
something didn't ya a teapot 3 year
round straight to tie it up 1 game of
peace what a statement here I mean it's
like that first match it even happen
yeah but now look how the opportunity to
set change the stage oh I'm guessing
we're gonna go to an infinite H a or
maybe Howard estate again who knows man
whatever you want whatever but yeah let
the match read a little bit the djinns
bent up you know right lines up in a
room issue
yeah he played very sharp the first game
second game I think you like a teapot he
just land more head somewhat Koopa hits
you and a teapot control of it so where
is he gonna go he has the opportunity to
change stage we're going mission but
dojo
keeping a simple final match here
thailand vs pakistan this is for winter
side toffee there is a lot on the line
mmm-hmm is it gonna be a teapot from
pakistan or is it gonna be thailand very
own book we're about to find out with
this final match he had the crowd on his
side he ain't got the headphones on you
they can have sometimes that power up is
what you need you gotta hear the people
right yeah Mishima dojo final game here
to stay on the winter side of the
bracket and the lesbian comes rock
let's go fist pound opening cool
hopefully they'll play this mid-range
poke game with the moon and Jin's pokey
very strong to believe it seemed uh
booked up and down back for kind of a
low poke at all leave a couple job cord
so that's it but they can get punished
but down to right like you give me
interrupting and punish get the first
one no floppy yeah yeah got the bubble
that's big though cuz you know he writer
that he lost three straight routes yes
so finally fighting back here some
momentum head Wow clean hit like fuzzy
duck egg throwing the Perry in there
everything odds of trying to find his
way in defense holding a paper book nice
center stage it's crazy the way he's
using that for for for he's kind of just
snapping his leg like a whip don't run
into it he's trying to pay something out
they both are
[Music]
set point book down to versus electric
with hook fist which one is better
this is for a spot in top eight winners
one round away book and he still has to
meet her though she chopped it he's bad
news
oh he's nervous the crowd all buddy
laughs big down right here wallet right
there yes you have another opportunity
for damage here nose for the demon flip
mix-up smart defend different book on
the ground he could've got guaranteed
hit that but did it go for it
he had the opportunity could have closed
it out there but he does but that's okay
for book he spent a bar meet so now he's
a true yeah very far away from another
one don't gotta close out this once he
doesn't get that meter back
one characteristic drops rubies at
countyman flip he did it go for the jump
if it's a boardwalk crowd coming alive
nice any she's gonna finish it he has to
do it now cook hot with the life lead
the downforce from downtown this time to
building that meters you have to be very
careful that he's put it's all good Lord
it you could have had the campaign nice
defense which he put here oh man guess
about me - yeah he's gonna hit our next
dumb oh oh here we go
party time uh uh whose party is it oh my
god this is dangerous
this is really dangerous he's got the
one bar here looks back is to the wall
in the back pull my 14 thank you what's
the color I don't know is that gonna hit
hey he's gonna get the lightning you're
not gonna kill I don't think they won't
kill and he has advantage and look at
the time put the deed but no time you
better make the noise right now oh my
god oh yeah
take it to the wolf just like that it's
gonna go in try to fight back here he's
gonna be close to getting a meter - this
is where it's gonna start to get hairy
but right now he doesn't have that much
like the local hero here we go talons
hook taking it to a final final round
white head stuff here man Wow and so
many uncharacteristic cardboard
dramatique but in that set but that's
what it is man when is in that that
clutch situation we haven't seen octave
go to that many international talking
book has been all over the world they
heap it cheapest not have too many
opportunities be able to play on a stage
like this dude you ever seen arena like
Tokyo ticketmasters had nothing wrong is
that afraid outright that it's a
completely different environment than
what he's used to and even on books in
right ABI what characteristic drops for
him yeah even as difficult as the
counter hit for it for combo isn't this
in this season I mean he's been lights
out for it for the most part some really
big ones big drops at the end of the
last game but that's got to do wonders
for his conference being able to win
sometimes a sloppy match like that you
pull out the win